of all his tell-alls it is by far the
most explosive but it may yet prove most
damaging to the author himself the
claims these Pages contain already
provoking a backlash on all sides
it is the revelations about Prince
Harry's military career that are
attracting the sharpest criticism his
admission that he killed 25 Taliban
fighters breaking an unspoken code of
combat
you could kill a hundred thousand people
but you just wouldn't say anything about
it Ben McBean served in Afghanistan at
the same time as Prince Harry and count
him as a friend but this time thinks
he's gone too far
he's a good guy and he's done so much
for the country and
at the minute it's all being
overshadowed by him revealing this and
revealing that
and it was just like just stop because
at the you know you think you're a good
guy hears him falling off the edge kind
of thing and he's getting close to that
his words have also somehow allowed the
Taliban to claim the moral High ground
with a senior figure denouncing the
prince's comments about not viewing
those he killed as people tweeting Mr
Harry the ones you killed were not chess
pieces they were humans they had
families who were waiting for their
return
the loss of his mother understandably
looms large in the book but even on that
topic he seems to be alienating would-be
allies
as the former spokesperson of Muhammad
al-fayed whose son Dodie died alongside
Diana Michael Cole supports Harry's wish
for a new inquiry into the crash but
says this is not the way to go about it
what is quite clear now is that he has
completely embraced Commerce the crown
is left behind his Royal status is just
a calling card and from now on he and
his wife are in the money business
for now the palace has stayed silent and
one imagines they'll remain so but the
heart of this book is really a very
tragic tale of loneliness of jealousy
and of unresolved trauma but all of that
is presented alongside the exposure of
family truths which at best seems
trivial but at worst seems spiteful and
so that's why Prince Harry might find
sympathy in short supply he's actually
in his words trying to put you know the
record straight unfortunately you know
there was no one to advise him in my
moon to say look perhaps is this a good
idea is it a bad idea you know and he's
decided almost on his own back to put
this out and uh of course it's going to
cause it's causing already huge problems
ahead of publication and so his attempts
to build Bridges may only serve to
deepen the rift a memoir that will be
hard to forget and forgive either
Bennett Sky News